do your patients call you dr mike they
mix it up dr varshawski dr mike what's
your last name
[Music]
wait what were you about to say no i
want to answer questions wait am i
supposed to
am i supposed to get them wait i wanted
to ask you why do i sweat so much more
than normal people this seat right now
is a swamp no literally i've been
sitting on this paper towel look how wet
it is
i don't care that you're sweating it but
do you want another paper towel no it's
okay it's very wet no but
so the reason why people sweat is again
usually for thermal regulation purposes
but i'll tell you why you're probably
sweating more
now than usual i'll do 10 jumping jacks
it's right here
what well i do drink coffee every day
but like everybody drinks coffee no you
can but i'm just saying after a cup of
coffee you're gonna sweat a little bit
more in that moment things that could
possibly be going on you have a
different metabolism than others
so you run at a slightly different
temperature you like to be a little bit
cooler so as soon as you heat up a
little bit your body wants to sweat and
cool down could there be something
medically wrong
it could be possible but you would have
other symptoms how come someday okay
wait where do i want to start here some
days i'll wake up
on sundays or some days some days okay
no i don't want to start there
let's talk about vitamins vitamins or
supplements i guess i don't know the
difference well vitamins exist in our
body and they exist in nutrients that we
eat food and
are very important to our survival we
can't live without okay supplements is
what you see
in gnc and vitamin shop those yeah those
are supplements those are vitamin
supplements
okay so you're talking about vitamin
supplements yeah people say like there's
no research that they work and then they
say like the amounts in them are so
bonkers should i be eating vitamins
every day okay you talking about
multivitamin
i take um magnesium biotin for my hair
skin and nails
d3 i was taking sunflower
what was it it was something for
bloating it was like sunflower
something dandelion root that's what it
was not sunflowers sure is that bad no
no
it's not bad why are you taking them the
magnesium was because somebody told me
to take it
because my muscles were sore okay the
biotin was because hair skin and nails
did you have a medical reason to take
any of these
my trainer told me to take them but he
doesn't sell them so it's not like you
know
no i'm not saying there's not going to
be any no knocking your trainer
most of the claims made by vitamin
companies and people who propagate
vitamin use have never been truly tested
okay word
we'll take multivitamins because that's
probably the most popular one that
people take do they extend your life
absolutely not
do they improve your quality of life
absolutely not all supplements are not
regulated by the food and drug
administration the fda if
right now you and i wanted to start a
supplement line called gabby and mike's
vitamin c magic potion to help you lose
weight we can put whatever powder we
want on this table put it into capsules
put it in a bottle and take it to a
store and sell it there is no rule
against that okay i have another
question
are manicures dangerous with like the uv
lights i wouldn't use the uv lights i
would just use the air dryers because
there's something called
dr mike you can't air dry a gel manicure
there's something known as subungual uh
carcinoma and it's basically
a cancer on your nail and like people
will see pictures if you google online
like a big dark line going down your
nail what's dangerous about that
is sometimes that cancer can appear
there no big deal but then if it spreads
to another part of your body it can be
deadly when i see a patient for the
first time when i'm doing a physical one
of the things i look at is people's
nails wow i wish i didn't have gels on
my nail right now so you can look at the
diagnosis
because i'm scared now okay i'm middle
eastern okay so i tan very easily
okay and i lay out a lot okay i always
tell myself
that because my skin is naturally tan i
am less likely to get melanoma
statistically you're right you are less
likely but you're still
increasing your risk but i love being
tan i'll tell you guys not only
so do you ever get burned maybe like the
first time like
the first time you're out in the summer
give me a rough estimate of how many
sunburns you've had in your life when i
was younger i would get sunburned like
relatively a lot so you're at a very
high risk of it but like now i literally
don't burn no you're very high risk now
that's
it i'm so much happier tan i literally
think that it does something to my brain
why am i still at more risk because i
tanned when i was younger
because i was burned but why don't i
burn now maybe you stay out less
definitely not maybe you wear some
sunscreen zero again you're gonna be
less likely to burn
than someone who is fair skinned that's
why people who are fair skin and have
x number of moles on their body you know
people who have a lot of freckles i have
so many moles
okay i'm scared because you have a lot
of moles and
it goes by numbers like 50 or more moles
you have x
risk and then if you have less than that
you have x risk wait more moles is more
risk yes i have
so my entire body so you have two major
risk factors
one the fact that you burned in your
life the fact that you have
many moles that puts you at a risk so
all i'm saying is
wear sunblock and number two make sure
that when you talk to your doctor you
get a full skin exam to make sure all
those i've had this mole looked at so
many times this does not look normal but
that is cancerous
how do you know look at it did you ever
get a biopsy no they won't but they all
just look at it and they say it's fine
i'm like look at it and i've went to
three different doctors
dermatologists yes then you're fine no
way
because it has everything that's they
say that you
look good do you think you should care
about doctors ratings on yelp
yeah you should you should read them you
should be an educated i have a story
i called an ent because i i had three
different problems do you have a primary
care doctor
no okay you should have a primary care
doctor i just like why would i ever go
there
what do they do so i'm a primary care
doctor right wait there was something
else i wanted to ask you too and i was
like getting so revved up and excited
something about your mole again
no it's not about my mole i need to move
on from the mole i've had multiple
doctors tell me i had a deviated septum
and then i went to a nose doctor and i
was hoping oh i remember what i was
gonna ask you about yes i went to an ent
when i lay down i literally can't
breathe like it's game over i'm like
mouth breather full out so i was like
okay deviator do you snore when you
sleep
like a mother like i'm a dinosaur but
when i go like this
i use rhinosaurus as the example of a
snore that's a better one
this is like crack to me you hear the
difference
[Music]
so i go to a doctor i'm like hey fix
this and he said it's not deviated
my septum is just so large but i can't
breathe i'm like okay did i just
pay 150 copay for you tell me i have a
big ass and i was like i know that but
he said
it's possible to shave down the septum
but he doesn't recommend it because it's
just like a really intense surgery like
it's not just like straightening it's
like we literally have to shave have you
ever got a sleep study done
see if you had a primary care doctor you
think about you think about snoring
right i can't stop doing do you know
what i worry about what do you worry
about heart disease what the
you can't talk to me like it's so
neurotic good i think in terms of
prevention
not just cures like you're thinking
about this problem directly in front of
you and what i hear is that you're
having snoring issues
you're needing to drink coffee multiple
times throughout the day or at least
once a day because your energy levels
are low do you love napping
i can't nap i have really crazy
nightmares have you heard of sleep apnea
i have sleep apnea i think because i
keep not breathing so do you know what
the issue of
sleep apnea is i'm like actually sure
long-term risk
of sleep apnea is developing high blood
pressure which then
affects the shape of your heart and its
ability i can't handle this today
this is about empowerment this is about
getting you to make the right decisions
for your health
i know i had a heart risk and i'm sad do
doctors actually read the charts because
i say
hard no what do you mean do we read the
truth like they make me fill out all
that
paperwork and then i come in 100 we read
the charts
none of my doctors read that because
then they ask me the exact same stuff
that's on the chart i'm like read the
damn chart also have you ever heard the
term flank in terms of medicine yeah
that's your side right there
i had a doctor tell me that i had a lot
of fat in my flank
anyways i don't know if you knew what a
flank was classically if someone has a
kidney stone
or an infection in their kidney which is
in the back portion over here and they
have pain in this area we call it flank
pain
that's the grossest word i've ever heard
about life or a body part well you've
heard a flank steak that's
well yeah because it's like like an
animal but like when somebody grab
literally grabs your side and says you
have a lot of fat in your flank well
that's
very offensive oh i remember how do you
feel about fillers
facial fillers yes okay generally do you
think that they're
unsafe do you feel light is generally
unsafe like
it can be an exciting yeah i mean like
is light ever bad for you yeah i'm so
stressed yeah what do you mean
blue wavelength light hurts your sleep
hormone the wave like life causes
macular degeneration to glasses
are you a surgeon yeah like my medical
license says physician and surgeon but i
don't perform surgeries on a regular
basis have you ever
yeah how long has been suited to surgery
really a long time c-section of medical
in residency we were tweeting about this
who me and you about c-sections yes
really
okay no you're blown right now when you
get a surgery
or a c-section they take your organs out
oh you said that what holds your
organs up fascia but then they put the
organs back and they
they're not like rebuilding the fascia
right when we cut through the fascia
we sew the fascia back up absolutely i
think i just don't have a very good
understanding of what
fashion is you just need to go to a
cadaver lab one time maybe that's a good
youtube video there is
no come on i'll vote this video and get
her put a comment on the thing
and if it gets 100 000 likes you can get
100 million likes but i'm not gonna do
it
can you generally get pregnant every day
of the month
yes okay that's all we don't have a
hundred percent accurate science to know
where exactly in your cycle that you are
yeah okay say yourself because we're
regular it doesn't matter it's still
not perfect why is my body so crooked
real talk
triple d double d nine and a half eight
and a half
like you guys are seeing i'm doing this
as evenly as possible and my right hand
is so much freaking it doesn't look so
much bigger you don't think that's so
much bigger look at this
shoes are annoying bras are annoying
like if i'm wearing a swimsuit like oh
this boob is so much bigger
oh my god i just remembered something
that's been haunting me my whole life
and then i have to ask you
oh sorry this is the thing each person's
heart is born with like
a certain amount of beats essentially
like you can only have like so many
beats in your life and that's why people
who like are overweight and their heart
is beating faster
or like unhealthy in some way that
that's why they die sooner so that i
used to get really scared to work out
because i was like oh my god my heart's
beating faster and i'm running out of
beets
yeah i would say it's totally inaccurate
okay cool it sounds like gross science
the reason why i would say is because
people that exercise and get their heart
rates up
they generally live long healthy well
her her combat to that
i know it is was that your heart beats
slower resting let's use an example like
lance armstrong whose
heart rate is incredibly high his
arresting heart rate is high and he's a
really high performing athlete and you
can't say that he's going to live a
short life because his heart rate beats
high what we've seen is a trend that
people who have lower resting heart
rates
are generally in better shape so they
live longer but it's not because of the
low heart rate that they live longer
it's because they're exercising you see
what i'm saying that has caused me so
much anxiety for a decade
well i am glad that we can control your
anxiety just a little bit
it's out of my brain all right guys i
hope you learned something we talked
about literally
everything under the sun so i hope you
guys enjoyed this if you have any
questions for gabby please drop them
uh down below in the comments please
check out her channel i'm gonna be
linking it everywhere she's in the
process of learning
so weird the entire that was good i was
like good watch how weird she stares at
me and judge her for me
and sorry to whoever has to edit this
jesus what about jesus wait jesus is
editing this who's jesus dan is editing
thank you dan sorry dan alrighty guys
thanks for watching as always
you have to do this too come on let's do
it as always stay happy and healthy
what do you think bo is i don't know
it's bacteria farts
yum generally when people are running in
the gym they don't smell bad but
when you're stressed you're fired
kids are taking cocoa powder that they
buy from amazon and they snort it to get
high
why are they getting online why don't
they just go to ralph's i don't know
what ralph says but word east coast
before we go can you tell me what blood
pressure
[Music]